and then as you kind of got into art and
got more sophisticated about it at what
point did you have the idea for master
works and kind of what was that original
idea of the genesis - hey I actually
wanna go blow a company here was really
that was really the time that the
blockchain stuff was you know then we
didn't totally fully appreciate the
regulatory dynamics with with what we're
doing today
you know we've now on up with fifty
three fifty four thousand people on the
platform you know every offering filed
with the SEC are socially was regulated
but FINRA nor a highly regulated
business so we initially thought of the
concept is kind of quick and dirty
started by the elephant which evolved
into something more complicated that was
the genesis got it and then kind of
explain today what that value
proposition is so I come in I create an
account what can I do and why would I do
that yeah you come to the master work
website today
create an account yet called their
membership team we like to speak to
every single investor that is interested
in investing on the platform and then
basically our offerings are investment
vehicles our single painting vehicles we
show you a particular painting we tell
you what the story over turns are of
that particular painting we have a risk
creating associated with the painting
you can read a full offering circular on
the painting race and learn how you read
an s-1 for a company going public like
uber you can read it s-1 equivalents
what's called a 1 a 4 for painting
painting calligraphy securitized with us
so we give you lots of information on
the artist the market that returns the
risk and you can make a case-by-case
decision on whether you you want to
invest in those offerings and then just
recently we were really excited about a
trading platform that we announced I
think roughly a month ago so it's in
beta we have one painting on it next few
weeks were rolling out more and more
paintings so people can can start
trading securities
so we've really taken an asset class
which historically is you know the only
way to allocate to is you have ten
million dollars by painting and we've
secured as has that so anyone can invest
in these paintings and trade securities
in its paintings so I guess there's a
whole bunch of questions in here but
when I buy into an offering right so
just say it's a Picasso it's ten million
dollars I put in some amount of money
how do you determine how much money is
like the minimum buying and then is
there a maximum in terms of how much of
that 10 million piece I can own yes we'd
like to talk to our investors like to
understand how they're busting today
what their risk tolerances are kind of
educate them on different segments the
art of market different risk profiles
and then trying to figure out what the
right allocation is for them to an
overall portfolio and and that's the
approach we've taken mainly because we
just very quickly learned that obviously
nobody knows how to think about and must
take an art so we try to provide some
some advice through through that process